THE STORY CONTINUES AND
TUCKER CARLSON IS READY TO TAKE
IT AWAY.
GOOD NIGHT, EVERY BODY.
YOU MONDAY
SEE YOU MONDAY.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON FOR IT
HE STILL TALKING, GOING ON A
LONG TIME.
THIS WEEK'S IMPEACHMENT TRIAL,
THE SENATE HAS DONE WHAT YOU
THOUGHT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE IN
THE ERA OF DONALD TRUMP, IT HAS
MADE POLITICS BORING AGAIN.
BUT THE TRIAL ISN'T DULL, IT
DULL IN A HIGHLY AGGRESSIVE,
ALMOST COERCIVE WAY.
WATCHING IT IS LIKE BEING
TRAPPED BY YOUR DRUNK
BROTHER-IN-LAW AS HE EXPLAINS IN
FORENSIC DETAIL HOW HE'S
MANAGING HIS 401(K).
AFTER 6 MINUTES, YOU FANTASIZE
JUMPING OUT THE WINDOW.
THAT'S THE EXPERIENCE OF IT.
FORTUNATELY, THERE ARE NO
WINDOWS IN THE SENATE CHAMBER SO
WE HAD TO WATCH THE ENTIRE THING
WE HAD TO WATCH THE ENTIRE THIN.
AFTER FOUR DAYS OF THIS, WE'VE
REACHED A CONCLUSION.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT A PHONE CALL
THAT DONALD TRUMP MADE TO
UKRAINE, NOT ABOUT ADAM SCHIFF'S
DREAM OF WINNING A DAYTIME AND
BECOME A TALENTED LESBIAN AS HE
IS, IT'S
BY CRITICIZING MIDDLE EASTERN
WARS AND PROMISING TO
DE-ESCALATE
TENSIONS WITH RUSSIA.
NOTHING HE HAS DONE BEFORE OR
SINCE HAS MADE THEM ANGRIER THAN
THAT DID.
DIRECT STRETCH OF THEIR IDEAS
AND THE PAYCHECK, ADAM CONCEDED
CLOSED THAT MUCH IN HIS CLOSING
COMMENTS.
HIS REAL CRIME WHICH OF MILITARY
AID FROM UKRAINE.
WHY?
BECAUSE IT'S AMERICA'S DUTY TO
REMAIN ON THE BRINK OF WAR WITH
RUSSIA INDEFINITELY.
>> THE UNITED STATES IS ROUGHLY6
>> THE UNITED STATES IS ROUGHLY,
>> THE UNITED STATES IS ROUGHLY0
>> THE UNITED STATES IS ROUGHLYT
>> THE UNITED STATES IS ROUGHLYO
>> THE UNITED STATES IS ROUGHLYP
>> THE UNITED STATES IS ROUGHLYS
>> THE UNITED STATES IS ROUGHLYA
>> THE UNITED STATES IS ROUGHLYI
>> THE UNITED STATES IS ROUGHLYN
>> THE UNITED STATES IS ROUGHLYD
IN EUROPE.
THEY SERVE ALONGSIDE TROOPS FROM
28 OTHER COUNTRIES THAT COMPRISE
NATO OR NATO.
>> THE PRESS IS NOT IN THE HABIT
TO EXPLAIN BECAUSE IT DID BE
NICE TO EXPLAIN WHAT THE HELL
HE'S TALKING ABOUT.
THE EUROPEAN UNION HAS FOUR
TIMES AS MANY PEOPLE AS RUSSIA
DOES BUT ITS ECONOMY MORE THAN
TEN TIMES AS LARGE.
RUSSIAN TROOPS HAVE NOT MADE IT
TO WESTERN EUROPE IN 75 YEARS
AND THEY WILL NOT BE COMING
ANYTIME SOON.
THEY CAN'T.
BY THE WAY, IF THE EUROPEANS
WERE WORRIED ABOUT A RUSSIAN
INVASION, THEY'D MAKE AN ARMY TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES.
THEY HAVE NOT DONE THAT BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT WORRIED.
ACCORDING TO ADAM SCHIFF THEM
AMERICA MUST KEEP 70,000 TROOPS
IN EUROPE AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILIES TO GUARD AGAINST THE
EVER PRESENT THREAT OF RUSSIAN
INVASION.
FOR REAL.
HE SAID THAT.
HIS FELLOW DEMOCRATS NODDED IN
VACANT IDOL AGREEMENT THAT IF IT
WEREN'T FOR MILITARY MILITARY
AID,
YOU'D HAVE TO LEARN RUSSIAN TO
SPEND JUNIOR YEAR IN FLORENCE.
WATCH.
>> RUSSIA'S INVASION OF UKRAINE
WAS A THREAT TO THE PEACE AND
SECURITY IN EUROPE.
IF MEMBERS OF THIS BODY HAD NOT
VOTED OVERWHELMINGLY ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS FOR MILITARY
ASSISTANCE TO REBUILD UKRAINE'S
MILITARY, THERE IS NO QUESTION
IT WOULD'VE INVITED FURTHER
RUSSIAN ADVENTURISM IN UKRAINE
AND PERHAPS ELSEWHERE IN THE
HEART OF EUROPE.
IT WOULD'VE WEAKENED OUR ALLIES
AND EXPOSED U.S. TROOPS
STATIONED IN EUROPE TO GREATER
DANGER.
>> Martha: BELIEVE IT OR
NOT, WENT ON LIKE THIS ALL DAY
LONG.
VOICE RISING, EYES BULGING.
STARTED TO SOUND LIKE A
CONDIMENT FROM BURBANK AND MORE
LIKE A CHARACTER FROM A TOM
CLANCY NOVEL.
THE GREATEST THREAT TO AMERICA,
SCHIFF SAID, IS NOT THE FIRST
GUARDS TANK ARMY, THE PRESIDENT
OF UNITED STATES WHO MIGHT BE
THE FIRST NONDRINKING VOTING
MEMBER OF THE POLITBURO.
>> IF A PRESIDENT CAN SO EASILY
BE MANIPULATED, TO DISBELIEVE
HIS OWN INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES,
TO ACCEPT THE PROPAGANDA OF THE
KREMLIN THE, THAT IS A THREAT TO
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> Tucker: BY NOW YOU MAY BE
WONDERING HOW IS THIS THE
IMPEACHMENT WE WERE PROMISED?
WASN'T IT SUPPOSED TO BE THE
ABUSE OF POWER, THE CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS?
AREN'T THOSE THE CHARGES?
HOW DO WE GET TO THE POINT WHERE
RUSSIA INVADES BELGIUM?
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME COMING.
THE GENESIS OF DONALD TRUMP
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL, TURNS OUT,
WASN'T THE NOW FAMOUS SCREENING
PHONE CALL OR EVEN HIS VICTORY
THREE YEARS AGO.
IT ACTUALLY BEGAN ON FEBRUARY
FEBRUARY 13TH 2016 ON THAT DAY.
THAT'S THE DAY THAT TRUMP
DEBATED JEB BUSH, TED CRUZ, THE
REST OF THE G.O.P. PRIMARY CREW
IN THE G.O.P. DEBATE AT
SOUTH CAROLINA.
SAID NO THINGS MAJOR REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES
HE SAID AMERICA SHOULD REACH AN
AGREEMENT RATHER THAN FIGHTING
PROXY WARS AGAINST THEM PRETTY
CALL THE TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS WE
SPENT IN THE MIDDLE EAST A
WASTE.
AT THE TIME, IT SEEMED LIKE
TRUMP WAS ASKED
ATTACKING REPUBLICAN ORTHODOXY.
TRUMP WAS ATTACKING THE
CONSENSUS OF BOTH PARTIES IN
WASHINGTON.
IT'S A NEOCONSERVATIVE
CONSENSUS.
BOTH PARTIES WORK TOGETHER TO
KEEP AMERICA OVEREXTENDED ABROAD
STUCK IN QUAGMIRES ACROSS THE
WORLD THAT IN REACH
KILLING OUR MEN.DONALD TRUMP A D
KILLING OUR MEN.DONALD TRUMP A F
KILLING OUR MEN.DONALD TRUMP A E
KILLING OUR MEN.DONALD TRUMP A T
KILLING OUR MEN.DONALD TRUMP A P
KILLING OUR MEN.DONALD TRUMP A H
KILLING OUR MEN.DONALD TRUMP A A
KILLING OUR MEN.DONALD TRUMP A S
A CANDIDATE, SAID IT'S TIME FOR
NOTSOME INTEREST OF SOME BACKWAR
NOTSOME INTEREST OF SOME BACKWAD
PETROL STATE.
TRUMP GOT THE NOMINATION AND
THEN WON.
BUT WASHINGTON STILL IS NOT
RECOVERED FROM THE SHOCK AND
RATHER LEARN FROM THE RESULT,
THEY DOUBLE DOWN.
THEY BLAME THE DEFEAT ON RUSSIAN
FACEBOOK ADS THAT NOBODY SAW.
AND IN RESPONSE TO THOSE ADS
THAT NOBODY SAW, THE DEMAND
AMERICA RISK WAR WITH THE
WORLD'S LARGEST NUCLEAR POWER.
WE'VE MOCKED ADAM SCHIFF MANY
TIMES IN THE SHOW AND WE HOPE TO
IN THE FUTURE.
BUT ON THIS MATTER, WE ARE